one of the biggest challenges in machine
learning is figuring out if your data
model has a bias
or a variance bias invariants are
related but they're two separate
challenges
bias is the gap between your predicted
value and the actual
outcome variance is when your predicted
values are scattered
all over the place you can have a high
bias and a low variance
in that case your predictions are
consistently wrong
but even worse you can have a high bias
and a high variance
that's when you're consistently wrong
but in a very inconsistent way
think of it this way imagine at an
archery range and archer effortlessly
let loose his five arrows
which landed in the center of the target
his target is a good example of low bias
and low variance
all five of his arrows were gathered
tightly in the center of the bullseye
another person never really shot a bow
and arrow before
but seemed to have a gift for it he let
loose his five arrows and had a
satisfying thwack as they landed on the
target
since he was a beginner he didn't have
the tightly grouped arrows in the target
instead he had a low bias that means
that his arrows were generally gathered
around the bullseye
but he had a high variance there was one
that landed straight in the bullseye and
the other four were gathered in the next
circle the third person shot five arrows
but they had a high bias and a low
variance
they were tightly gathered in the upper
right hand corner of the target
he did shoot the arrows consistently but
he was consistently wrong
finally the last person had a couple of
arrows in the corner of the target
one in the tree behind the target and
another that landed just in front
he had a high bias and a high variance
his arrows were spread around the target
and he
overshot or undershot the mark remember
that bias and variants are ways of
measuring the difference between your
prediction
and the outcome they're not right and
wrong answers but different dials that
you need to improve your predictions
the key thing to keep in mind is that
you'll use different techniques based on
whether you have too much bias or too
much variance
when you know which challenge you face
you'll be better equipped to tweak your
hyper parameters and make better
predictions